but if any Tory MP has a community Doris
moment and talks about posh boys you
don't know the price of milk William
Hague will be so these are attributed
working class and the north um and also
the kind of statesmen gonna mean a David
Cameron's doing things in the long term
interest of the country um then he got
Grant Shapps as their kind of the
enthusiastic Tory party cheerleader
mm-hmm then you've got Michael Gove for
when dynasty just want to shut a story
down he is chief whip but quite
unusually for chief whips can do a lot
of media you know in the remember when
Maria Miller was resigning Michael Gove
was on the way in the cab to his labor a
time to defend Maria mother and then it
turned out Marilla resigned before he
got to the studio so he did it into
beyond ruffled yeah exactly and he is I
think one of the other things that they
like about him is they think that
Michael Gove but because he's a kind of
former hack himself because he's so
articulate and makes news their theory
is that you can basically when you're in
trouble you can call this vapor episodes
we've just put Gove in a cab he'll be
out broadcasting house in 20 minutes and
there's a program or clear the slot and
on he'll go and then you have estimate
vaise there's the fourth Minister for
broadcasting but i think is designed to
be the kind of slightly surprising that
you know that the Liverpudlian woman and
you again defines the kind of idea what
the Tories are all a bunch of posh boys
so we were told a day ago that Esther
McVey will be the minister for
television and that would be it from
what you've seen we've now got a
minister radio 1 radio to radio forward
really of five yeah I mean I think I
thinks it almost forgetting to could
have designated we don't it's a radio 3
Minister yet do you Michael Gove his
love of our group can easily do then
they can administer for radio 3 um but I
think you see that kind of thing and
also go you look at some of the other
appointment pushpa tell it's gone to
Treasury one of the mean is that most
appeals are about pretty Patel to the
torrian hierarchies that they believe it
you can use her equally effectively to
attack both labor and nuke it so I think
you'll see uh-huh on the economy trying
to do that I mean it was very
interesting that when Cameron address 22
dev week he basically told them that it
was the economy that was going to bring
new Kip people who'd gone to you get
back to the Tories
I think we're going to see Britta Patel
doing a lot of that kind of small
business you know the tax cuts we have
already given you all that kind of stuff
I think will come from her today it does
seem to be a shift away from government
towards electioneering with a reshuffle
pretty much designed for campaigning
which is here yeah I think so i think if
you're looking for ministers you have
particular policy expertise is quite
difficult to find a lot of them who've
we've been appointed but they're good at
selling policies they're good at
defending policies that might be
unpopular so actually that they're
gearing up as jane says for that
broadcast or is not going to be about
kind of policy banchory over the next
few months it's going to be about trying
to beat em at abandoned doing it in the
most effective cut through way possible
but can we physically take 12 months of
electioneering i don't know i think if
you like talking about policy probably
not but i think one of the other things
you see it is is this the center is is
strengthened if you think about these
these these meetings that we have in
Downing Street all the time you're now
gonna have us born in them Hague in them
Govan them Cameron in them be camera in
other words he's got a higher quality
comfort blanket yeah and he's basically
saying that we need political brains at
the center people are going to roam
across government you know I think one
of the things that which is potentially
what magic is what it is month although
still gonna be on always cabinet
committees he's still gonna be doing is
gonna have a lot more time to do right
round and one of the things that got on
trees amazed nerves was this sense that
Michael Gove was it was pretty his nose
into other people's business yes now
he's got a license to interfere and he
has ideas are going to prime ministerial
license to to interfere which it which I
think could lead to some quite
interesting confrontations one of the
other things about this is it's a
complete change in the nature of the
role of chief whip because I'm the chief
whip in kind of you know when i'm
michael job spook 100 was there Negron
when andrew mitchell was appointed on
the last time Cameron did it have big
reshuffle to achieve win drop I'm much
was made of the fact that his nickname
at school of being fresher and that you
know the idea was you wouldn't want to
cross Andrew Mitchell Michael Gove is
okay
temperley sometimes see but he's
incredibly polite normally as he wasn't
abused trips people doesn't he a school
he was bullied Ashley there's a group of
kids who call themselves the Gulf
Buster's who went around trying trying
to beat enough the curry guys so he is
the opposite to Andrew Mitchell he's a a
charmer rather than a Thrasher I suppose
that the flip side to him being very
good at defending the government when
things have gone wrong on this day
program or something like that is he
also does as you say like to make forays
into any policy area and that's gotten
into trouble in the past and putting him
in a war broadcast focus role is useful
but also dangerous because you could see
him intervening on the Second World War
as well as the first loves to go off yes
d and tell you about the battle of the
somme no hell can pick was I thinking
about my movies probably I think one of
the other things about this is is that
cabinet is going to become a lot dollar
because of this reshuffle cuz if you
look at lots of people have gone and Ken
Clark always used to speak up and speak
his mind about things pastan always used
to speak up and speak his mind about
things so I think that you know I mean
looking they'll be all the more
importance on the go of interventions to
kind of keep cabinet livelier than
conveyed it